Jesus is the embodiment of the
revelation of God
as a human being. He's both the
messenger and the message. Okay, so
what makes him the message?
Because his life is the his life
reflects the the supreme truth of the
universe. What what about his nature?
Because now this is where I'm going to
get confused with the Unitarian
position. What about his nature
made it such where he can embody God's
word perfectly, flawlessly, but that's
never been the case for any other human
creature, not even Adam prior to fall,
prior to sin. Um Adam was flawless like
Jesus. How was he able to pull it off?
Um
well, one I believe cuz he was chosen to
do so, and two, I believed
um But Adam was chosen to be God's image
bearer and also have dominion over God's
physical creation and when he was
chosen, he was flawless and perfect.
I what what what I'm I'm not talking
about his nature. I think we we but you
agree that Jesus was fully a human
being, right? I
of course, but he's also truly God in
the flesh. I have an answer why he could
be flawless, but I'm forget about my
position. I'm trying to use your logic.
Yeah, well, well, two things. One, we
read in the book of John that Jesus was
given the spirit without measure. Okay.
So this is Jesus given the
eschatological
amount of the spirit, so he's given a
higher amount of the spirit than
anybody. The spirit is what empowers us
Yeah. to receive into
the mind of God. Okay, but two things.
Number one, why give him the fullness of
the spirit and not, let's say, Moses?
That's number one. And number two,
that you're talking about the baptism
where the spirit came upon him to
empower him. How did he do it up until
the baptism? How did he do it from
when he was a baby till he was 30? How
did he get away without sinning?
I think
he just he just chose to do it.
So what what was it about his nature
that made it possible for him to do it
and no other human being has been able
to do it, not even an Adam
with a perfect body and a perfect nature
in a perfect world, and he failed?
He he he chose to do it. I don't I don't
I mean a lot of Unitarians explain it
that because he was born of a virgin
that his sin has I mean that his flesh
had some sort of nature in which it
wasn't prone to sin.
>> Just like Adam, right? Adam was formed
out of dust. That was virgin dust and no
one had defiled the dust from which Adam
came, so that wouldn't answer it either.
Well, yeah, not yet. What I would say is
that simply
that Christ chose not to sin and that
God God loved him because he chose not
to sin. So God's love was conditional
upon Jesus's obedience, but beyond that,
that still leaves the mystery.
I choose not to sin, and yet I still
succumb to sin. My goal is not to wake
up in the morning and sin against God. I
don't want to sin against God. I want to
honor God, but I fail miserably. Now
you're going to say, "Well, my nature is
tainted." Okay, put that aside.
We go back to Adam again. Adam,
virgin dust,
perfectly designed, fresh from the
manufacturer's own hand,
had the breath of life animating him,
seeing God face to face in a perfect
world, and he still failed. And yet this
human Jesus, this merely human Jesus,
somehow did it. What was his secret? I
don't know. You don't know because you
keep insisting that Jesus can only be a
man, no more, no less.
Well, then but but at the same time that
you assume it's because he was God. So
here we have two assumptions.
But my assumption's anchored in the
Bible. That's why I can show you that he
is God cuz he can do what only God can
do, which is why he could be impeccable
and flawless.
Okay, but now we're getting kind of
delving off. I'm okay with that, but
let's make sure we have the other part
right. But
but I don't think we're going to make it
very far with this conversation, this
part of this this aspect.
>> Jesus being God part? You want me to
passages where Jesus is God?
Uh no, not if we if we if we if we're
ready to move forward, I I welcome it.
That's great.
But we're not we're not we're not
talking about we're talking about
potentiality
to sin. Yeah. And Jesus had that
potential?
Yes. And yet for some reason, according
to you, a merely human Jesus, even
without the fullness of the spirit
coming upon him from the time he was
born till 30, managed to So he didn't
even have a sinful inclination. Not even
a sinful desire.
I think he did, yeah. You think he did?
I I I would say that if he's tempted in
every way
that that that's only significant if he
had the potential to sin or Finish the
passage. This is what happened. It
didn't say he was tempted. It said he
was tempted without sin.
Yeah, he had he So he was tempted to So
the we're talking about the temptation.
If he didn't have the potential to sin,
I would say the potential is the the the
temptation is insignificant. Okay, two
two responses. Number one,
I'm not asking if he had the potential.
From the time he was born till he was
30, he never sinned in his heart, never
had a sinful desire I don't know. I I
think that's an argument from silence. I
I think we don't The Bible's quite
clear. He's been impeccable and flawless
because he's the holy one from his
conception. That's what the angel said.
He's the holy thing. But secondly, you
again assume that if you're tempted,
that means you must have the potential
to sin. You just condemned Jehovah as
someone who has Well, maybe I should ask
this. I don't know what you believe
about God. Do you believe God the Father
has the potential to sin as well?
And the define sin there. Meaning he can
have a desire to sin, but he overcomes
it. Whatever you define temptation. If I
tempt you to sin, you're saying you have
the potential to sin.
Can God
have the potentiality to sin if
>> [clears throat]
>> or he has no potentiality, so that means
no one can tempt him.
Well, I think we're getting back to
human nature here. No, it's not just
human nature cuz what you said was, "If
Jesus could be tempted, then he must
have the potential to sin."
I want to know if you're going to stick
with that because the Bible says God has
been tempted all the time, so according
to you, he must have the potential to
sin.
I think the dynamic is different. If you
want to bring up some verses where God
has been tempted
>> I can. But only question is, it's going
to affect the translation because you
and I I don't know if you know, but I'm
going to assume you know, the word
translated tempted is also translated
tested, but it's comes from the same
Greek and Hebrew words. So for example,
if I should tell you, "Go to Psalm
106:14
in the New Revised Standard Version."
Read it in the New Revised Standard
Version or I'm going to read it in the
King James. And it's the same Hebrew
word that in some places is rendered
test, other places is rendered tempted.
Okay? Same Hebrew word. Psalm 106:14.
You can read in New Revised Standard
Version. Watch here.
I'm going to show you something.
Phyllis, please. I'm talking to someone
in text. Phyllis, don't chime in. You
Let me deal with this [clears throat]
and I'll get back to you, Phyllis,
afterwards. Sorry, I'm just on with
somebody in text. Go ahead, brother.
Read uh
Psalm 106:14 in the New Revised Standard
Version.
Okay.
106:14, Psalm 106:14, "But they had a
wanton craving in the wilderness, and
God put to test
and put God to the test in the desert."
>> Now let me read the King James.
"But lusted exceedingly in the
wilderness and tempted God in the
desert. They tempted God." And it's the
same word. That's why the King James
rendered it tempted. So that word tempt
is also translated test. It's not a
different word. So here God was tempted
in the desert. Go to Deuteronomy 6:16.
Tested to sin?
No, just the same way that God Jesus was
tempted, and yet he could not sin.
Any temptation against God is a sin. I'm
The the this is a different
different form of testing, it appears. I
haven't looked into it, but there's
nothing about God sinning or having the
potential to sin here. Okay, how Let me
let me let me
let me let me address that. When when
Satan tells Jesus to throw himself off
the pinnacle
because God would command his angels,
what did Jesus quote to him? "You shall
not tempt the Lord your God," right?
Sure. What was what was the temptation?
What was the nature of temptation?
Was that a sinful one because Satan is
instigating Jesus to tempt God? So this
is tempting God in a sinful manner?
No, I don't I don't think so.
>> What then what would be wrong with it?
Why is it called temptation? What
You're saying so if I tempt God, it's
not sinful.
It's not it's not in Yeah, it's
it's not going to have it's not give
it's not God putting it putting God in
the predicament of where
him questioning or or reasoning, "Should
I sin or not?"
>> well, it is because you're putting God
in a predicament to do something that
was contrary to his prescribed will
because here the God's prescribed will
for Jesus wasn't for him to throw
himself off the pinnacle and put on a
display. God's prescribed will for Jesus
was to be humble and assume the status
of a servant and not come with with pomp
and stance. So if he did that, he would
put God in a situation to go against his
prescribed will, and that is sin.
>> [clears throat]
>> Well, what is the context in which he
said that?
>> Well, I mean, the reason why I mentioned
that it's because Jesus was quoting
Deuteronomy 6:16.
And there it says, "You shall not tempt
the Lord your God as you tempted him
at Massah." So they did tempt him
and shouldn't do so again. What's my
point? Just because someone is tempted
doesn't mean he has the potential to
sin. You can tempt God all day, all
night, he will not succumb because he
has no sinful proclivities. Similarly
with Jesus, just because you can't tempt
Jesus, he cannot sin, which is why he
passed the test. That's the point I'm
trying to make.
>> [snorts]
>> I I see I see the point. I don't think
it's valid, but I I do see where you're
going.
>> Well, then you John 5:19, you have
problem with John 5:19 because he says
he can do nothing on his own initiative,
but he can only do what he sees God
doing. So, if Jesus could do something
sinful, so could God because he just
said, "I can only do what God does."
John 5:19.
The language is explicit. John 5:19.
The son cannot do a single
thing on his own initiative. He can only
do what he sees the Father doing. So, if
Jesus could do something sinful, so
could the Father because he said, "I can
only do what he does." So, it is a valid
point.
That's John 5:19. Well,
>> [clears throat]
>> So, so the bottom line is you're saying
Jesus did not have the potentiality to
sin.
>> Exactly.
Okay.
Yeah, that's a biblical teaching. I I I
disagree, but I'm I'm glad we understand
each other. I think that's great.
>> How long has it been now we've been
doing cuz I enjoy this discussion. How
long has it been now, seriously?
I haven't been taking time.
It's been I have no idea. Um Okay, it's
been 72 minutes.
If If you want to ask me questions where
Jesus is called God, we can discuss it.
If not, maybe we can do a talk on Marlon
cuz Marlon is here. We can set up
something for him because I do want to
also take questions from other people
cuz I think we've we've hammered this
part about the Logos and Jesus. So, if
you have another question about Jesus,
like say, is he called we can do that
because I want to talk about something
else, not because I'm not interested in
this, but it's been 72 minutes on the
same subject. Is Jesus the Logos? Is
Logos the Jesus? Or is Jesus simply the
embodiment of the Logos? So, if you want
to ask me a question, is Jesus called
God? If so, where? And is it
functionally? We can adjust that. It'll
be a new question, still [snorts]
relevant.